Reviews, like design, testing, and coding, are software development activities.
As such, they can be measured to see how effective they are.
The key statistics to compute are the following. First off, the review rate
in lines of artifact reviewed per staff hour spent reviewing. Second is
defect rate in the number of defects detected per staff hour spent reviewing.
Then from those numbers the defect density is the defects per line of artifact.
This can be used to indicate whether the process of producing that
artifact is leaving too many defects in it. And then, process yield
is computed by comparing the review detected defects to total defects,
or how do you know what the total defects are? One way of getting a total
defect includes those defects detected by other means, such as testing and
those that are eventually reported by users of the delivered product.